[Musique]
m
bonjour à tous et merci de nous
rejoindre pour ici l'europe en sept
semaines bruxelloise encore très chargé
alors dans notre seconde partie nous
parlerons d'ailleurs des frontières
intérieures et extérieures de l'union
européenne met tout de suite passage en
revue de l'actualité européenne avec le
vice président de la commission
européenne vice président slovaque maros
sefcovic merci d'être avec nous vous
êtes le président aux relations
interinstitutionnelles c'est à dire qu'à
ce titre vous occuper beaucoup du
royaume uni et puis à la prospective à
ce titre vous vous inquiétez de l'avenir
de l'union européenne vous êtes du parti
socialiste européen qui a longtemps été
au pouvoir en slovaquie qui a été plutôt
des faits lors des dernières élections
de juin
passez à un parti anti corruption alors
vous êtes commissaire depuis 2014
les 27 n'ont pas trouvé monsieur le
commissaire d'accord jeudi sur le budget
et le plan de relance plan sco club post
covin menacée par un veto hongrois
polonais et slovènes les gouvernements
nationaliste au pouvoir
le pis donc droit et justice de jaroslaw
kaczinsky en pologne et le fidèle de
viktor orban en hongrie sont en conflit
depuis plusieurs années avec bruxelles
sur leur traitement de l'indépendance de
la justice et des médias
alors comment vous percevez ce veto ah
oui bien sûr c'est très malheureux parce
que la situation très sérieuse pour nous
c'est d'accord politique qui a été
obtenue pendant l'été après cette
semaine de quatre jours n'est est très
important pour nous le plan de relance
la perspective budgétaire pluriannuel et
bien sûr de next generation et aux
instruments soient absolument clé pour
la durée démarrage de l'économie
européens maintenant qu'on vous avait
dit nous avons un accord politique entre
le conseil et le parlement européen
ce qui nous a surpris beaucoup c'était
vraiment
un veto de l'engrais d'être des polos si
le commentaire critique slovène hier des
régions européennes on a touché sur ce
sujet pas beaucoup de temps parce que
maintenant tout le monde spécialement la
président la présidence allemande de la
chancelière merkel est bien sûr notre
président ou sa faune de la n1 président
du conseil européenne monsieur michel il
entend ma les négociations avec
notamment le dpi pour trouver un
compromis parce que je crois que pour le
citoyen européen pour les entrepreneurs
européens absolument nécessaire d'avoir
ce budget en place d'avoir la
possibilité de vraiment redémarrer nos
économies en europe
oui parce que cela compromet
effectivement la levée sur les marchés
en commun à 27 2 750 milliards d'euros
pour financer ce plan de relance est
bien ça le problème
oui parce que je peux dire que cette
proposition de budget c'est d'accord
politique des tests c'est vraiment je
crois je peux dire que c'est un pas
historique parce qu'elle pour la
première fois l'une européenne peut
travailler avec la sombre en pot à 81 2
trillions d'euros c'est quelque chose
qui est extraordinaire mais en même
temps absolument nécessaire et important
pour rédémarrer nos économies alors les
slovaques y crée partie avec la pologne
et la hongrie du groupe devise grade
votre pays donc mais pourtant elle se
désolidarise sur cette question là et on
voit bien que et bien il n'y a pas un
bloc de l'est qui est totalement
d'accord qu'il ne faut pas contrôler
l'état de droit qu'est ce qui se passe
exactement
oui vous savez raison parce que ici on
ne peut pas on ne peut pas dire qu'elle
est à quelques divisions entre
l'ouest et l'est parce que nous avons
seulement des pays se séparent à
visegrad 4 essentiellement vraiment la
pologne hongrie qui revue 7 lion entre
le droit d'état monitoring et bien sûr
l'utilisation de défense européenne j'ai
beaucoup de confiance à la présidence
allemande et bien sûr à nos dirigeants
ici le président de la commission
européenne et du conseil européen pour
trouver une solution parce que tous les
maux en besoin de ce soutien financière
je dois souligner inclut le citoyen les
entrepreneurs hongrois et polonais oui
précisément les pires belle figure parmi
les premiers bénéficiaires des fonds
européens 4,5 pour cent du produit
national brut de la hongrie vient de ces
fonds qui pourraient bénéficier de 16
milliards d'euros entre 2021 et 2027
c'est énorme
ils ne pourront pas s'en priver
éternellement ils seront d'ailleurs
peut-être rattrapé eux aussi par la
crise duco videront besoin de ce plan de
relance
vous jouez là dessus vous espérez que ça
ça va débloquer les choses
oui veut bien sûr j'espère ça parce que
toutes nos stratégies de relance tout ce
travail qui a été entamée par les pays
membres sur développement de des plans
de relance ça continue c'est déjà bien
avancé et c'est qu'on a besoin bien sûr
ce sont les sources financières qui
étaient approuvés en corde a été trouvé
des gens arrêtés
c'est pourquoi maintenant c'est vraiment
jeu plus dur très irresponsable de
vraiment présenté quelques
revendications est de réouvrir les
négociations qui étaient déjà fermés
alors c'est vrai que le parlement
européen par exemple s'est montré
inflexible sur la défense de l'état de
droit il s'agit de contrôler le bon
fonctionnement de cet état de droit pour
les vingt-sept pas seulement deux pays
mais pour l'ensemble des pays européens
et de c'est peut-être très important
quand même dans cette crise du coup rona
virus on est soudé état d'urgence des
mesures d'exception à les citoyens ont
besoin que leurs droits soient
réaffirmés oui bien sûr parce que nous
sommes maintenant en crise pas seulement
crise des coûts vite mais on voit déjà
le mal reste conséquences de la crise
économique
on voit que le marché de travail et en
grands problèmes et nous avons vu les
premières chiffres
sur spécialement là j'ai gens qui sont
maintenant menacés de perte de l'emploi
et c'est pourquoi c'est absolument
nécessaire de vraiment démobilisés de
ressources financières pour trouver les
meilleures options qu'on peut faire face
à la crise sanitaire à la crise
économique et à la crise d'emplois c'est
pourquoi j'espère que les dirigeants et
tous les dirigeants seront responsables
parce que maintenant on a une grande
opportunité de réding redémarrer nos
économies de vraiment ouvrir je peux
dire en nouvelles chapitre dans le
développement européen dans la gestion
de la crise qu vise il ya eu pas mal de
cafouillages de manque de coopération la
commission européenne par exemple a pris
en charge l'achat de vaccins et pourrait
donner son feu vert
donc dès décembre à moderna et finder
est ce que ça c'est une bonne nouvelle
pour les européens que ce campagne de
vaccination va démarrer
oui je crois que c'est de très bons
nouvelle et j'espère que ce sont
vraiment la première fois pour ce
revenir à la vie je peux dire normal
standard et je crois que cette crise qu
vite nous a rappelé comment la santé
publique est importante pour nous tous
c'est comment la coordination européenne
est primordial pour trouver la meilleure
solution pendant le christ si dramatique
que nous avons aujourd'hui vous avez
raison la commission a investi beaucoup
et nous avons déjà signé les sangles
contrats avec les fournisseurs de
vaccins
on a déjà je peux dire réservez 1.2
milliard des vaccins pour le citoyen
européen de ce que sera en pourtant très
important maintenant sera de faire un
beau logistique la distribution des
vaccins mais aussi de commencer je peux
dire en campagne d'information pour
expliquer aux citoyens européens
pourquoi c'est nécessaire de se vacciner
pourquoi c'est nécessaire de coopérer
ensemble pour vraiment gagner contre 7
virus pasquet on a déjà beaucoup de
dommages causés par sa en europe alors
on a vu une firme américaine comme
modern à mettre la pression sur la
commission européenne pour qu'elle
achète des vaccins selon ses termes
on comprend bien que finalement il ya
quand même derrière des lobbys
pharmaceutiques qui qu'ils veulent ces
achats et parfois et bien certains vous
reprochent trop d'opacité dans les
négociations de ces achats de vaccins
qu'est ce que vous répondez je peux dire
que nous avons réussi beaucoup de
complément des ministères de la santé
européens parce que spécialement le
petit peu olé olé pays
moyon ont compris que ce sera presque
pas possible pour est de négocier
avec les géants pharmaceutiques
mondiales avec de très souvent les
avocats américains est très chargé et
c'est pourquoi c'était très important
qu'est la commission européenne
c'est de couper de tout ça avec notre
expérience et notre jouerie scène on
aujourd hui nos avocats parce que vous
avez raison c'est de négociation était
extrêmement dur extrêmement difficile
mais le succès ici parce que je crois
que l'europe est non très bien stocker
nous sommes très bien préparés nous
avons comme jeudi réservé envers le 2
milliards des vaccins pour non citoyen
je crois que c'est très très bonne
nouvelle alors maros sefcovic vous êtes
beaucoup coupé parlons d'un autre
dossier très important le breakbeat au
titre des relations
interinstitutionnelles vous avez été
plusieurs fois au royaume uni parce que
boris johnson le premier ministre a
promulgué une loi remettant en cause le
protocole déjà signé dans l'accord de
divorce sur l'irlande du nord
vous avez d'ailleurs été interpellé par
les leaders de cette irlande du nord est
et de l'ecosse également en qui juge
inacceptable qu'il y ait à ce stade
incertitudes sur la solidité de cet
accord sur l'irlande du nord
moins de deux mois avant la fin de la
période de transition qu'est ce que vous
répondez oui vraiment je veux faire
présenter tout mais complément
michelbach rien c'est mon ami c'est
notre négociateur en chef et il fait là
travail remarquable pendant quatre ans
il a négocié avec nos partenaires
britanniques
les négociations sont très difficiles
très dur et c'est pourquoi nous étions
extrêmement un mécontent quand le
royaume uni a décidé de ne pas respecter
l'accord de retrait qui était signée
décembre dernière et qui est entré en
force
en février c'est pourquoi j'étais chargé
de par notre président de l'entente met
immédiatement et les consultations des
deux indes et refuser de dynamiser les
négociations avec mon partenaire chance
l'argovien parce qu'il est parce que
nous sommes les co présidents de comités
jouant entre le royaume uni l'union
européenne sur l'application
l'implémentation de d'accord des
retraits et bien sûr le problème le plus
difficile
et comme on va appliquer le protocole
d'irlande d'irlande du nord parce qu'il
ya beaucoup de choses qui sont liés avec
notre promesse et engagement politique
vers un hoogerland pour pour eux avoir
la possibilité de rester en marché
unique en même temps de bien sûr
continuer d'être là la partie du royaume
uni mais maintenant je dois dire que
nous travaillons beaucoup ensemble et
j'espère que toutes les préoccupations
tous les problèmes qui sont là avec le
protocole avec le l'accord des retraits
seront réglés nous sommes en contact
fréquent et nous préparons notre
prochaine session dans les jours qui
viennent alors les pourparlers il bute
sur trois gros sujet des garanties
réclamées à londres en matière de
concurrence
l'accès des européens aux eaux
poissonneuses britannique et puis la
manière de régler les différends dans le
futur accord les discussions entre
michel barnier que vous avez mentionné
david frost l'autre négociateurs
britanniques sont suspendus à cause d'un
cas de kovy de 19
est-ce que vous avez encore l'espoir de
réussir cet accord avant la fin de la
période de transition 31 décembre tout
de même au khyber bien sûr ça externe
malheureux mais c'est comme on travaille
maintenant qu'elle
chaque chaque jour on a quelques
surprises très souvent les surprises
très très difficile mais je sais que
michel grands négociateurs qui
travaillent traître d'une manière très
dure
immédiatement on a décidé de je peux
dire ceviche de transférer nos
négociations à la manière virtuelle
comme on a fait pendant la première
vague des décos vite je peux dire que
maintenant vous avez raison nous sommes
très proches est très loin en même temps
parce que on doit trouver un accord sur
tous les sujets qui sont importants pour
comme le royaume uni
bien sûr pour l'union européenne et ce
sont trois sujets que vous avez
mentionné
bien sûr la pêche la gouvernance est
aussi les questions de concurrence qui
doit être résolu et qui doit être aussi
acceptable pour tous nos pays membres
c'est pourquoi sont les négociations
c'est difficile quand même temps nous
devons aussi démontré que le royaume uni
va respecter les accords que qui a été
déjà signés c'est pourquoi maintenant on
travaille sur se détraque parallèle mais
celle sur le futur et moi sur sur le
le présent et je peux dire aussi le
passé parce que comme je dis c'est
l'accord était déjà signé et maintenant
doit simplement s'appeler s'impliquait
s'appliquait merci à vous monsieur le
vice-président de cet entretien merci à
vous de nous avoir suivis à vous restez
bien sûr avec nous je rejoins dans
quelques minutes marie brémaud pour
explorer les frontières européennes
frontières intérieures frontières
extérieures s'est tout de suite
[Musique]
bienvenue dans la seconde partie d'ici
l'europe pour engager le débat aux
frontières de l'union européenne car
certains pays ont été tenté de refermer
leurs frontières face à la pandémie du
coc vide 19 mêmes
suite aux attentats de nice et de vienne
pour lutter contre le terrorisme sauf
que nous sommes désormais dans un espace
de libre circulation des personnes voilà
trente cinq ans que nous nous déplaçons
sans passeport ni contrôle à l'intérieur
de l'espace schengen qui regroupe 26
pays européens la mobilité
transfrontalière est très importante à
chaque jour ce sont deux millions
d'européens qui passe une frontière
européenne pour aller travailler dans
divers secteurs essentiels la santé
l'agriculture et la distribution est
depuis la crise migratoire de 2015
l'union européenne s'est efforcé de
rendre étanche ses frontières
extérieures aux migrants illégaux en
particulier elle s'est également
déchirés sur les contrôles au fauteuil
aux frontières intérieures dans le cas
de la migration dans le cas évidemment
de la coopération contre la menace
terroriste que reste-t-il du coup de
l'idéal d'une europe qui fait tomber les
murs et les frontières et pour en parler
nous irons en belgique à bruxelles un
pays qui a très peu fermé ses portes
pour retrouver marc tarabella eurodéputé
socialiste et démocrate
bonjour et depuis paris à quelques
encablures ilana cicurel député européen
mario new le partir du président
emmanuel macron qui a fait polémique
suite aux attentats
en parlant de réformer en profondeur les
frontières extérieures et intérieures et
encore avec nous christiane silvio
bouille
bonjour vous êtes vous eurodéputé du
parti populaire européen depuis bucarest
alors précisons que votre pays la
roumanie n'appartient pas aux 26 pays de
l'espace schengen
elle voudrait bien y appartenir mais on
lui reproche de ne
briser assez ses frontières en extérieur
précisément mais on va commencer avec
vous marc tarabella face à la pandémie
même l'allemagne à un grande défenseuse
de la libre circulation a fermé ses
frontières
elle l'a rapidement regretter un reflet
qu'un réflexe national et surtout
déraisonnable 1 selon la chancelière
oui d'abord schengen est un dossier
fondamental de la construction
européenne d'ailleurs et c'est vrai
qu'il ne convient pas le remettre en
cause
globalement parce que la libre
circulation entre les différents pays de
l'espace schengen est une des grottes
plus value de l'union européenne au fil
des années on s'en rend pas comblé
jeunes se rend pas compte mais quand on
est quinquagénaire comme moi et qu'on a
dû patienter à des frontières à chaque
fois et montrer ses parties pour passer
d'un pays à l'autre simplement aller en
vacances ou en revenir
bah c'était quand même une équipe
pénible c'est un des grands acquis qui
peut être aménagée en fonction des crise
que l'on vit ça je peux comprendre qu'on
aura l'occasion certainement leur parler
or dans le courant du débat mais de fait
jouer avec schengen c'est jouer avec le
feu l'europe a déjà perdu beaucoup de
crédibilité à certains égards au niveau
de ses citoyens par une série de
politiques qui sont menées çà pas le
débat du jour mais à un moment il faut
la gagner il faut l'arganier cette peur
cette popularité de l'europe qui elle
était très populaire au début de sa
construction
au fil de sa construction est
aujourd'hui un désenchantement schengen
si on s'attaque à schengen je vois plus
ce qui restera comme comme grande plus
value et donc il faut vraiment faire
attention être très prudent et là je
trouve que le président macro et d'acier
imprudent alors justement ça c'est une
référence vous l'entendez bien madame
cicurel à la phrase du président macron
qui a la foi disait qu'il fallait
réformer les frontières extérieures et
intérieures et que ça n'a pas été
toujours bien compris puisque pour ce
qui est des frontières intérieures en
effet chaîne glenn nous oblige à une
libre circulation une libre circulation
qui profite aux français d'ailleurs ce
qu'il ya des centaines de milliers de
transfrontalier qui vont travailler de
l'autre côté de la frontière et c'est
bon pour le chômage croît qu'il ya un
procès qu'on peut pas faire au président
macron c'est de ne pas être européen il
a été élu sur son attachement à l'europe
et je crois que c'est ce qui fait je
crois
qui fédère tous les français qui se
reconnaissent en lui
alors le fait le procès sur chaque
phrase est ambigu sur schengen donc
faisons le professeur expliqué voilà
alors alors moi je pense moi je vais
vous dire deux choses tout à fait je
pense que depuis le début le présent
macron et nous en tant que député
renaissance on a défendu sa pendant la
campagne c'est qu'il faut réformer
schengen et réformer schengen c'est
certainement pas remettre en cause la
mobilité au sein de schengen mais c'est
simplement avoir plus de responsabilités
plus de solidarité notamment et ça
c'était dans notre programme
il faut le faire c'est notamment un
examen ce qu'on appelle un prix
screening aux frontières extérieures
c'est à dire que quand vous avez des
demandes pouvoir beaucoup plus
rapidement
en cinq jours décidé que certaines
certains candidats essayent d'utiliser
les failles du système et ne relève
absolument pas du droit d'asile et cela
les à main doit se faire facilement et
la reconduite hors d'europe doit se
faire aussi très rapidement et cela va
permettre un accueil beaucoup plus
humain et respectable de tous ceux dont
les candidatures sont légitimes donc ça
c'est le premier élément
ensuite il ya le renforcement de frontex
qui d'ailleurs a été décidé la frontière
extérieure et aux frontières ont débuté
ses skis et ski escape fait c'était
alors surface et rieur sur les
frontières intérieures moi je voudrais
revenir à la pandémie est ce qu'on a
vécu on a une il ya une grande
différence entre la première vague et la
deuxième vague lors de la première vague
on n'était pas prêt il faut le dire et
vous savez à l'intérieur de schengen tel
qu'il est pensé aujourd'hui vous pouvez
avoir des contrôles aux frontières ce
n'est pas interdite par le traité
et je pense qu'on était dans un cas qui
nécessitait parce qu'on n'était pas
prêts parce que vous le savez la santé
n'est pas de la compétence de l'union
mais il ya une coopération qui est
possible et disons le franchement on
était très en-deça de ce qu'on aurait pu
faire au niveau coopération donc vous
avez eu des frontières et ça a été
choquant pour tous les européens d'aider
fermeture non concertée des des
fermetures anarchique et c'est pas du
tout satisfaisant si vous comparez avec
ce qui s'est passé dans la deuxième
vague
et entre temps il y avait eu un conseil
d
des chefs d'état et de gouvernement
européens qui avaient décidé que s'était
engagé à ce que ce ne soit plus le cas à
ce qu'il n'y ait plus de fermetures
qu'est ce qui avait changé entre les
deux étapes
eh bien vous aviez eu une coopération en
matière de santé beaucoup plus forte et
donne un exemple très clair ces camps
s'étaient mis d'accord par exemple sur
les tests qu'on considère comme valide
chez nos voisins européens mais l'aja
vous avez une reprise de cette
circulation et donc je pense que ce cas
en tête emmanuel macron si je puis me
permettre son exégètes ce matin c'est
précisément que il faut repenser cela
c'est à dire des coopérations plus forte
parce que l'objectif c'est bien sûr la
mobilité c'est au coeur de l'europe
alors tout le monde se met demande que
deux mois sa présidence mais par contre
il faut s'armer pour que pour que pour
que cette cette circulation se fasse
dans les meilleurs contrôles en temps
mais face à la crise sanitaire mondiale
de l'europe et à sang quand même point
de vue un puisque fermer les frontières
c'est une des réponses au virus défendue
par la hongrie ou la république tchèque
s'est pas efficace d'un point de vue
sanitaire monsieur vous y
la première vague de la pandémie
candidats étaient vraiment un choc pour
beaucoup d'entre nous n'oublions pas que
pour certaines branches sur l'économie
la fermeture de frontières aidé
considérant ce des conséquences
considérables
je garde et le front intérieur ouvert et
sur la coopération en matière de santé
très important c'était déjà fait beau ou
par la commission européenne
nous avons un nouveau programme je suis
le rapporteur au parlement européen où
on a déjà quelques mesures qui sont
prises on aime le l'union européenne de
prendre d'autres mesures avec la
nouvelle agence européenne une système
schengen moderniser les contrôles
systématiques nouveau système d'entrée
le système européen d'information de
teck d'autorisation donc il y a des
solutions
et si je suis d'accord avec la position
du président de la république 106
c'est marrant qu'on doit renforcer les
je veux vous dire que l'harmonie alambic
tous les conditions techniques
ça a été déjà mieux
ils étaient tous 2011 aussi ne parle pas
européen mais il n'y a pas unanimité
dans le conseil c'est plutôt décisions
politiques papaye pour ça j'espère que
bientôt la roumanie sera pas de l'espace
schengen mais les conditions techniques
sont remplies les investissements sont
faits est un moyen technique même
beaucoup plus supérieur que du pays du
sud de l'europe où ge avons vu dans la
crise migratoire
les frontières sont assez perméable et
c'est ça c'est dommage
vision politique madame cicurel
on passe plutôt au chapitre qui est
aussi intéressant je pense de la menace
terroriste parce que c'est ça justifie
en grande partie les propos d' emmanuel
macron en effet le tueur de nice par
exemple est entrée illégalement par
l'italie et c'est toujours effectivement
un poste de friction entre la france la
france et l'italie cette frontière
le contrôle à la frontière donc de la
zizanie s'est à nouveau posée qu'est-ce
qu'on change par rapport à cette menace
terroriste maintenant qu'est-ce qu'il le
faudrait qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait
rectifier d'abord il faut se dire que on
ne part pas de rien c'est à dire que la
menace terroriste est une menace
transfrontières c'est une menace
transnationale donc d'abord il faut dire
et rappeler que l'échelle européenne et
la bonne échelle pour lutter
efficacement contre le terrorisme et on
ne part pas de rien parce que déjà en
2015 vous aviez eu la mise en place de
la directive anti terroriste nous avons
un centre européen de contreterrorisme
nous avons le fameux passenger name riz
cordes c'est à dire la france avait
beaucoup poussé pour que l'on n'ait
accès aux données des passagers qui
voyagent par avion dans le cadre d'une
enquête terroristes vous avez eu la
création d'une dune d'une agence d'une
d'un centre de renseignement européens
et vous le savez on est en train
d'avancer sur des choses intéressantes
comme un parquet européen est ce qu'on
appelle un f biya européen c'est à dire
que qu'europol voit considérablement ses
compétences élargies en matière de
renseignement donc en fait il faut
d'abord dire que la frontière
elle n'est pas totalement pertinente
dans en matière de terrorisme
on sait que nos ennemis sont sur
internet et donc ce qu'on s'apprête à
voter et on a eu beaucoup de mal à le
faire avancer c'est à dire le retrait en
1h02 tout contenu terroristes c'est
quelque chose qu'on doit faire à
l'échelle européenne et même en réalité
à l'échelle internationale et donc ça si
vous voulez face à une menace qui est
elle même de nature transnationale
ce n'est pas la question des frontières
qui est totalement pertinente et je
crois que l annonce trenton manière
forte et si vous savez il ya eu 31
attentat déjoué en france depuis le
début du mandat de démêlés de macron je
peux vous dire que la coopération
européenne en matière de sécurité et a
été a été a joué un rôle majeur
on entend déjà les chansons nouvelles
auront avancé considérablement
on l'entend marc tarabella quand même
quand votre voisin français parle de
réformer en profondeur schengen pour
faire face notamment à la menace
terroriste est ce que vous vous
inquiétez quand même d'un repli
nationaliste son big parce que vous
venez cité l'exemple d'un obscur et les
derniers attentats dont la france a été
victime mais si on parle du bataclan du
du magasin casher de charlie hebdo et en
est d'autres malheureusement ce sont des
gens du territoire et la belgique a
souffert des attentats aussi commis par
des gens du territoire et donc attention
au repli sur soi effectivement je pense
que la surveillance effectivement des
réseaux sociaux
l'interdiction de certains contenus
peut-être quand on est fiché abandonné
faire l'objet d'une surveillance
beaucoup plus étroit et peut-être d'en
empêcher de nuire à certains moments oui
sans joie qu'il faut peut-être renforcer
les choses là dessus la circulation je
reviens parce que j'ai pas pu m'exprimer
en réaction temps je suis un défenseur
un défenseur de schengen et notamment
des frontières intérieures autant à
certains moments de manière transitoire
on pourrait envisager de fermer les
frontières
l'exemple nous vivons aujourd'hui
attaque au vide et je reviens de
secondes a su en belgique où tout le
monde vit à moins de 100 kilomètres
d'une frontière
nous sommes tous des frontaliers en
belgique et bien aujourd'hui ce qui est
interdit les magasins qui sont interdit
d'ouvrir et bien leurs clients vont à
l'étranger vont aux pays bas vont en
allemagne vont aux lords à laufon hier
au luxembourg
et c'est évidemment sujet d'une
frustration et ces gens vont restaurants
vont dans les magasins
ils reviennent et donc si on voulait
être efficace je pense qu'à un moment
donné il faudrait probablement fermer
les frontières avec évidemment des
exceptions humanitaire ou se rendent à
l'étranger pour un décès ou ouveau des
raisons médicales
allez à l'étranger d'accord mais pas
pour des raisons d'agrément parce
qu'aujourd'hui qui sont frustes et ce
sont les personnes qui sont victimes
économiquement de fermeture et je ne les
remet pas en cause s'est fait remettre
une louche mais complet les citoyens
vont à l'étranger faire exactement la
même chose
la sarre frustre les citoyens beaucoup
de commerçants sont en ouvre aujourd'hui
et ils ont raison
fermeture temporaire donc à nos dépens
du pâté et alors par rapport à
l'extérieur il faut pas défendre
l'europe forteresse non plus l'euro
malheureusement on a failli en matière
d'accueil des gens qui je le rappelle
fouiller la guerre fuis fuis la guerre
c'était le cas en syrie
ce l'allemagne et la suède ont joué
pleinement leur rôle d'accueil est
aujourd'hui madame merkel est félicité
par le patronat allemand évidemment les
zones situation économique il permet
d'avoir fait rentrer un million de
réfugiés qui se sont intégrés dans la
société et c'est évident on en sort un
jour c'est un lacet un vaccin inventé
par deux tueurs immigrés qui sont venus
un jour en allemagne et qui ont fait
leurs études ils étaient en file sur ces
leurs études et aujourd'hui vont
peut-être nous permettre de sortir du
corps y croyez encore à cette abolition
des frontières on l'entend monsieur
musée du depuis la roumanie
chaque attentat effectivement on parle
de mieux sécuriser ses frontières
extérieures qui vous intéressent
beaucoup de l'union européenne mais
finalement est-ce que les états sont
prêts à ce que ce que vous mettez en
scène à la fois monsieur terra bella et
madame sécurel à savoir finalement un
grand saut fédéraliste vers une police
des frontières européennes ou un
garde-frontière italien pourrait
contrôler en hongrie par exemple et par
la même occasion un super fbi est ce que
c'est c'est seulement on en est loin
quand même
on est là c'est bien sujet je vous ai
dit il y a des yeux et concret ce qu'on
a on a fait pas mal ou peur et je crois
que la situation sera meilleure
on doit lutter contre les tories
avec tous nos jours ça c'est très clair
jours à paris et à lyon gardez la
frontière longue ligne ou d'autres sera
plus d'espèces
parce que là problème ces femmes d'être
seulement là les frontières de l'est
et ce sont des frontières du sud au
moins pour la crise migratoire pour les
terroristes
la situation encore plus compliquée mais
bien sûr on doit renforcer les
frontières extérieures
on doit changer niort les informations
ont d'ailleurs la roumanie même s'il n'a
pas été frappé mais nous sommes très
vigilants et aussi très très résolus
pour renforcer les frontières pour
renforcer la lutte contre les
terroristes pourraient être puisque en
europe à l'intérieur de l'union
européenne pour être par delà la
solution votre règne toile et sur
l'année contre le terrain il faut bien
faire attention que ne pas faire un
amalgame entre terroristes migrants tous
les terroristes ne sont pas migrants et
tous les migrants sont pas terroristes
bien évidemment mais je voulais rebondir
par rapport à ce que vous disiez un peu
plus tôt il s'agit pas de fédéralisme
vous savez en europe il ya qu une seule
question qu'il faut se poser et elles se
résument dans un principe qui a l'air un
peu technique mais qui est très simple
c'est la subsidiarité est ce que dans la
lutte contre le terrorisme
on est plus efficace au plan européen la
réponse est oui et donc il faut le faire
au niveau européen
merci à nos invités d'avoir été en notre
compagnie
vous restez un sur nos antennes pour la
suite des programmes
[Musique]